le sud de rennes on a retrouvé le
sourire avec l'annoncé d'un premier
ministre ce matin le spectre de la
fermeture de la voie ferrée tours loches
semble s'être éloignée une bonne
nouvelle pour ce territoire fragile qui
se bat au quotidien pour conserver
malgré tout une dynamique de
développement et d'attractivité qui
sentent le fait qu'on n'a pas une ligne
et une desserte sncf satisfaisante
on va dire décrédibilise un petit peu
l'attractivité du territoire via le
réseau ferré pour attirer des salariés
qui pourraient se déplacer via le réseau
ferré de tout reproche on ne sait pas
encore si la ligne tours loches va
pouvoir se développer comme on le
souhaiterait mais dans tous les cas la
porte n'est plus fermée même
satisfaction chez sud touraine
entreprise une association qui regroupe
plus de 70 entreprises
pour eux la perspective de développer le
ferroutage est aujourd'hui très attendue
aujourd'hui on a beaucoup de
marchandises et on a des grosses
sociétés ont besoin de libérer de
l'espace se libérer du volume et déplacé
des marchands disent très rapidement on
sait qu'aujourd'hui
voilà quelqu'un qui commandent faut que
ce soit le lendemain chez lui avec la
voie sncf pourrait libérer le secteur
car le fai re routage est déjà utilisée
sur cette ligne à reignac entre tours et
loches justement cette plateforme de
stockage de céréales historique utilise
depuis longtemps le train pour
transporter ses 175 mille tonnes de fret
par an autant de camions en moins sur la
rd 943 déjà très chargé et une question
importante c'est l'intervention de la
concurrence à supposer que cela soit
décidée ça veut dire que la question de
l'existence et de la vie de cette petite
mine ya peut-être reposer donc moi c'est
non pas un doute pour douter c'est un
appel à la vigilance à l'objectif de
mettre cette ligne sous la
responsabilité des citoyens tous
confondus reste l'enjeu de demain pour
être réellement exploitable la ligne
doit être rénové un coût certain pour
les pouvoirs publics et des décisions
dont on ne sait pas encore acquis de
l'état ou de la région elles reviendront
finalement